now we're going to get reaction from our
panel in just a moment but first here
with a full report out of Israel our
very own Alex Hogan is with us Alex a
lot going on there today and of course
uh Joe Biden and the administration
putting a lot of pressure on the
Israelis to quote hit the pause button
uh in the middle of the ground
Invasion hi Sean that's right so we saw
US Secretary of State Anthony blinkin
here today and he laid out what he says
are America's priorities in this
conflict and those are to not only make
sure that this conflict doesn't spill
out to other countries but send in
humanitarian Aid make sure that
Americans are able to get out create
safety for the civilians there create a
a long-term approach to establish peace
in the area but of course to save those
hostages we believe that among other
things uh a humanitarian pause could uh
help that effort uh could facilitate it
it's one of the reasons why uh we're
focused on
it well prime minister Benjamin nyaho
here in Israel says that a ceasefire is
simply off the table especially as the
IDF continues to push forward into
Northern Gaza dismantling infrastructure
and going after those key Hamas targets
at the same time International
organizations are warning of the dire
conditions for civilians who have not
fled out of that area the White House is
saying that as many as 100 US citizens
and their family members were able to
get out of Gaza today and that about a
100 trucks carrying humanitarian Aid
Service supplies and all of that was
able to get in to those in need Sean all
right Alex you've been uh doing a great
job please stay safe there hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else